i'm definitely surprised and a little
startled by how crazy the left has gone
over the last 10 years i mean
in part this is a consequence of
demographics right the left is basically
the party
of upper middle class and upper class
elites
and then some working-class minorities
who are sort of still along for the ride
on the democratic party
but really those folks don't have a ton
of influence in the party right
uh so it's partially just sort of who is
leading the left
i think it's it's like you know
professionally educated people who went
to ivy league schools
who tend to have pretty radical views
about politics because of it
i think a little of it is definitely
economic i think the the left
is not comfortable with the fact that a
lot of people are dissatisfied with the
way
the economy has worked the way the
manufacturing economy has worked
and instead of saying you know maybe
this is a serious problem that we've
like
lost our entire manufacturing and
industrial base to china i think their
response is to complain
that the people who care about our
industrial base in the first place
they're obviously racist or xenophobic
or idiots
so i think part of what's going on is
it's just like the composition of the
left has really radically changed
but part of what's going on is the left
completely unable to solve america's
real problems is sort of resorted
to criticizing most americans as
backwards or racist in some way
and so yeah it's really startling it's
really depressing
but you know it is it is where we is and
i unfortunately you know
it is what it is and i think
unfortunately we just have to fight
these people
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the author of hillbilly elegy
a memoir of a family and culture in
crisis
founder of the venture capital firm
naria and current
senate candidate from the great state of
ohio
jd vance welcome to the reuben report
thanks for having me dave good to see
you
good to be with you you know i wanted to
chat with you for a while
because i i find that on twitter i find
some people
who make some sense who actually are
saying some things that actually
seem like a sensible way forward for
this country for this earth the whole
thing you
you're on that short list uh for people
that don't know who we are
uh can you give a little bit of the
backstory that's sort of what the book
is about and then the movie but can you
just give me a little brief bio just to
kick us off
yeah sure so i was raised by my my
working class grandparents in middletown
ohio which is in southwestern ohio it's
a steel town
and the basic story is because of a host
of complicated reasons but one of which
is that my mother struggled with opioid
addiction
you know my grandparents had to take
care of me and we grew up in pretty
rough and tumble environment didn't have
a lot of money didn't have a lot of
support
but things sort of worked out for me as
i like to say america worked for me
and i think it really did for for a
number of reasons but
two two reasons at the top of the list
or my grandma was always very
loving and supportive she was as you
know dave because he read the book but
she was not a traditional grandmother in
a lot of ways she loved to say the f
word she had 19 handguns when she died
but she was also a woman of incredibly
deep faith
and then i also was well served by the
us marine corps and i listed in
april of 2003 which is right as the iraq
war was ramping up
you know marine corps was this
incredible experience for me gave me a
lot of
a lot of important lessons a lot of
lifelong friendships um
and then you know from there went to
college
with the law school uh sort of started
working in silicon valley and the
technology industry
uh got connected with uh with peter
thiel out there and then
while i was working with peter actually
published this book hillbilly elegy
which happened to coincide how could i
possibly known with this remarkable
political environment that we lived in
2016
where you know donald trump on the right
was coming out of nowhere and taking
over the republican party
you know bernie sanders was coming out
of the left and almost taking over the
democrat party
and so i sort of found myself all of a
sudden a national commentator and i'm
glad that you like my twitter
uh you know a lot of a lot of your
colleagues in the media don't but uh
i'm not sure they're my colleagues but
they they are in the media
whatever that is but but you bring up an
interesting point there because you yeah
that sort of put you on the map around
2016 the trump thing's happening
and in many ways your story and and the
book and then the movie
sort of is the story of the people that
kind of supported trump right
yeah it is so you think of the story of
my family so my grandfather was like a
working class blue dog democrat he was a
classic
steel union democrat socially moderate
very patriotic loved his country but
sort of always saw democrats as the
party of the working man and the working
women
by the time you know trump came around
in 2016
most of those non-college educated you
know classic white working-class white
voters
uh that was sort of the the buzz award
in 2016. they had shifted so hard to
trump and so i think a lot of the reason
that the book did very well
is people were picking it up trying to
understand like who are all of these
voters
who even you know some some a lot of
white work class voters actually
supported barack obama in 2008 or 2012
but had this really hard shift right in
support of donald trump
and so i think a lot of folks were
trying to understand what was going on
and the book
obviously benefited from that were you
surprised that there was a jump
from those values being in the middle of
the country
steel workers industries changing all
that and then to an actual political
movement from a guy who was a real
estate developer in new york
you know it's it's interesting i i
definitely found
the reaction to the book as sort of this
political insight into a lot of voters a
little bit weird because
you know the book doesn't mention
clinton it doesn't mention trump it's
not really a political book
uh in in the classic sense uh but i
understand why people are trying to
understand like why do these folks in
the middle of the country
feel left behind so condescended to and
of course
they feel left behind they feel kind of
send it to you because in many cases
they actually are
they have been left behind they have
been uh looked down upon
by a lot of folks in power so i
appreciate that
people were at least for a brief period
trying to understand that demographic of
the country
uh so so obviously the book benefited
from that and and i think hopefully it
did provide some insights from that that
group of people or
to that group of people yeah you
mentioned the blue dog democrat i'm not
sure how much you know about my story
but i
i was a lefty i was a progressive the
whole thing but i would say
if the blue dog democrats still existed
but they're basically like the unicorn
at this point
there would be maybe some room for me to
say i could kind of be on that side
probably not at this point but do you
think that person exists anymore and if
they do exist
are they basically just a modern
conservative i mean is that is that sort
of what you
are at this point yeah i i think that
the people like that certainly exist i
think donald trump fits into that where
to your point even though he was a real
estate developer i think he's he's
at his cart right he's a guy from queens
who works with a lot of working-class
people construction workers sales people
and so forth
and so he's always identified with those
folks at a deep emotional level and
they've identified with him
you know donald trump is up there i
certainly think my you know my my
attitude towards politics is like a
working class or a blue collar
conservatism
uh there are other people out there i
think jim banks is a really interesting
guy representative from indiana i think
tucker carlson
talk about another guy who's sort of you
know an east coast
wasp in the classic sense but i think
identifies with blue-collar folks
in a very deep way and obviously focuses
a lot on them in a show so i think there
are actually a lot of us
out there who think the the purpose of
the republican party should be to better
serve its voters
um but but i think they're all on the
right at this point i mean there there
were maybe a couple of blue dog
democrats
even five ten years ago they all got
primary they
all got effectively kicked out of the
party and they're just clearly not
welcome there anymore so if they exist
at all they're they're sort of on our
side of the aisle
yeah i mean that's what i've been saying
i know a few of these people and i think
it's
kind of a worthy fight if you want to
still say you're a democrat and try to
you know do something as the house is
burning down
but it just doesn't seem like it could
work to me are are you uh
are you surprised how radical the left
has gone that there is no room for these
people i mean i guess
as someone running for senate now you're
kind of excited it's like yeah come over
here we're all right um
i'm definitely surprised and a little
startled by how crazy the left has gone
over the last 10 years i mean
in part this is a consequence of
demographics right the left is basically
the party
of upper middle-class and upper-class
elites
and then some working-class minorities
who are sort of still along for the ride
on the democratic party
but really those folks don't have a ton
of influence in the party right
uh so it's partially just sort of who is
leading the left i think it's it's like
you know professionally educated people
who went to ivy league schools
who tend to have pretty radical views
about politics because of it
i think a little of it is definitely
economic i think the the left
is not comfortable with the fact that a
lot of people are dissatisfied with the
way
the economy has worked the way the
manufacturing economy has worked
and instead of saying you know maybe
this is a serious problem that we've
like
lost our entire manufacturing and
industrial base to china i think their
response is to complain
that the people who care about our
industrial base in the first place
they're obviously racist or xenophobic
or idiots
so i think part of what's going on is
it's just like the composition of the
left has really radically changed
but part of what's going on is the left
completely unable to solve america's
real problems is sort of resorted
to criticizing most americans as
backwards or racists in some way
and so yeah it's really startling it's
really depressing
but you know it is it is where we is and
i unfortunate you know
it is what it is and i think
unfortunately we just have to fight
these people
where do you think trump now fits into
this thing because you you were not on
board the trump train in 2016 right you
did vote for him in in 2020
um where do you think he sort of is now
like the worth of trump at this point
yeah you're right i was i was a late
adopter to trump um and i remember peter
thiel giving me crap for it back in 2016
and of course eventually said you know
you're you're right you were right
the guy was uh was was was saying a lot
of smart things
uh did support him in 2020 i mean i
think at a fundamental level trump
is still the leader of the republican
party right um
so to the extent that you have this blue
collar patriotic movement within the
country
it's on the right most of those voters
are still very loyal to donald trump
and so i think he continues to have a
very important voice
either as a king maker in the party
certainly i think if he ran in 2024
there's a very good chance
uh he'd get elected president again so i
i
tend to think that trump has is is not
going to disappear as a force from
american public life
and i think you know unfortunately
most republicans or at least most
republican leaders i think most
republican voters are very good about
this
most republican leaders i think don't
fully appreciate what trump represented
and so there isn't an obvious like
answer to trump if he just disappeared
tomorrow i do fear a little bit
that if trump just went the way of the
dodo you know decided well i'm gonna
focus on making money or i'm gonna go
play golf all day and not really worry
about politics anymore
like i don't know that there's an
obvious person to replace him right
there are some really good people like
desantis like josh molly
um but but but outside of a few really
bright politicians
i think most people don't want to fully
embrace what trump represented for the
republican party which is which is a
tragedy
because i think it's it's ultimately you
know quibble with some things on the on
the margins but i think it's the right
direction for the party to go right so
you're saying guys like desantis and
holly are better than
uh romney and liz cheney is that that's
the few is that the controversial
statement you're making yeah the the
radical claim that i would make is that
josh hawley is much better than liz
cheney
and ron desantis is better than mitt
romney um but but but again
unfortunately i
actually think though the most elected
republicans
are not as far out there as liz cheney
um
they really don't like what trump
represents they sort of want the party
to be what it was during the bush era
2000 2004
and because of that there's still a lot
of resistance i mean even one of the big
takeaways from the trump administration
is that when the entire party is
institutionally set against
the will of the president himself there
can be a lot of real bureaucratic fights
and i think so much of what
happened during the trump administration
is you know the trump trump folks wanted
to do something on trade
they were somewhat successful they were
also fought by members of their own
party
and so you don't just need one
politician you sort of need the entire
institution to reform itself
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell